fight on you gotta stay strong get up
off the ground deep down I know you got
the heart of a champion oh who did that
I wasn't me girls don't poop
well someone pooped so how many times
have you been out with her three how
does that make you feel happy good it's
good it's now that's really good news
why would Olivia do that yeah her
relationship Fitz is very complicated he
is the worst
well not as bad as Mellie though right
hey don't even get me started
hold on gotta stay strong listen to the
sound
have you been texting your ex no Elliot
this is a safe space
maybe oh my god why why would Ron do
that says he's a goddamn winner that's
why if he's not as good as Kevin Durant
right oh don't even get me started on my
voice I know you've got the heart of a
champion
it's whatever Jess I don't tell you so
good good what do you think you're
wearing that on a date yeah where you
going
TJ Fridays yeah actually uh oh uh I
would still change yeah that looks like
my shirt
nice totally a shot hey guys this is my
friend Sasha who's my roommates um I'll
be right back I love this outfit I know
thank you
yeah the keys oh my god sometimes he
cries in his sleep
oh the night balling up good night yeah
yeah and I caught him in the bathtub
with a martini that's the family huh
won't you tell her listen to the sound
of my voice
like it drowning you feeling like you
lost and on and on something I know
you're gonna turn it around feel it the
lighting